bonjour à tous et bienvenue à vous au
grand rendez-vous bonjour François
Bayrou bonjour c'est votre grand
rendez-vous ce dimanche président du
MoDem maire de Pau au commissaire aux
plans
cette émission se passe au moment où la
France est toujours groggy par la
monstrueuse attaque d'Annecy groggy et
en même temps François Bayrou la France
relève aussi la tête grâce à l'homme au
sac à dos Henri et aux Français dans le
courage et l'abnégation force le respect
et plus largement cette attaque pose de
nombreuses questions sur la politique
migratoire européenne sur l'asile et sur
notre souveraineté alors surtout ces
sujets et sur la suite du quinquennat un
remaniement à venir et surtout le projet
de société pour vous interroger mes
camarades Stéphane Dupont des Echos
bonjour à vous Stéphane bonjour et
Mathieu bocotte bonjour Mathieu bonjour
François bayrouin rassemblement citoyen
aura lieu d'ici une heure à Annecy un
moment bien sûr de partage alors que les
victimes sont fort heureusement hors de
danger un moment aussi de reconnaissance
vis-à-vis de l'homme au sac à dos Henri
j'ai suivi mon instinct géagis comme un
français devrait être agir à dit celui
dont on admire le courage et
l'abnégation avec un peu de recul
aujourd'hui selon vous qu'a-t-il
réveillé en nous cet homme
ce garçon a été courageux a été
courageux
non pas pour prouver quelque chose mais
pour faire quelque chose
la plupart des gestes que que vous
relayez que les que les écrans
reprennent assez souvent dans le moment
qu'on vit dans la société ils sont faits
pour montrer pour prouver quelque chose
lui il est allé simplement parce que
quand vous êtes devant des événements
comme ça et que vous êtes
un homme
il a dit un français sans aucun doute
mais un homme tout court
ce sont c'est une attitude humaine
il a courageusement poursuivi
l'auteur de ce de cette
inimaginable agression il a couru je
pense poursuivi lui a couru après on a
vu ça
et ça prouve que
alors que tout le monde dit c'est une
société d'où le courage a disparu dit ça
pour tout le monde pour les responsables
politiques pour les professionnels pour
les médias pour pour
la vie de tous les jours il a montré que
c'était pas vrai
et il a montré qu'on pouvait encore
croire à des choses qui nous dépassent
c'est
hésiter à l'afficher François bayraud il
a d'ailleurs aussi affiché via le
drapeau français qu'il porte fièrement à
son bras il a mis en avant sa foi
catholique il fait le tour des
cathédrales de France est-ce que ce
parcours là ce parcours singulier est
aussi un exemple est-ce qu'il a eu
raison de le mettre en avant je vais
vous dire comme vous savez c'est pas un
secret je suis croyant
et même comme on dit entre guillemets
pratiquants c'est pas ce que ça veut
dire grand chose mais mettons
et cependant j'ai aucune envie de tirer
dans le sens
de l'adhésion religieuse
ce que ce garçon a fait et je suis sûr
qu'il partagerait cette formulation ce
que ce garçon a fait
n'importe quel
fille garçon
dans les mêmes circonstances qui
auraient en lui ou en elle la même
aspiration leur effet aussi ça n'est pas
le geste d'un chrétien d'un catholique
français c'est le geste de quelqu'un qui
est responsable devant
les siens devant ces frères humains
et
on a vu des
c'est un événement je sais pas si on
connaîtra un jour le fin mot de cette de
cette histoire parce que la folie joue
un rôle la folie le déséquilibre mental
il joue un rôle très important pour
n'est pas avérée d'abord alors si c'est
pas du déséquilibre mental c'est quoi
c'est l'objet de l'enquête
qui s'est passé
ce
cet homme syrien
ayant obtenu l'asile en Suède
venu en France tout le monde a pensé au
départ que c'était
une agression connotée d'islamisme et
puis on s'est aperçu que il disait je
sais pas si c'est vrai qu'il disait
qu'il était chrétien d'Orient vous
comprenez que le parquet national
antiterroriste n'est pas été saisi dans
cette affaire
je ne sais pas honnête de j'ai aucune
envie de me substituer à la justice et
aux enquêteurs est-ce que c'est du
terrorisme je ne sais pas quel
est est-ce que c'est une bouffée
délirante je ne sais pas vous voyez bien
le tout le monde a essayé de tirer dans
un sens
d'obsession d'obsession
politiques politicienne sur une attaque
aussi
ignoble ouais bah il y a toujours de la
récupération politique il faut il faut
laisser ça de côté
sur un riz alors on le sait vous étiez
catholique il revendique mais c'est son
tour des cathédrales français fier
français qui porte son drapeau formé
dans le scoutisme c'est peut-être pas au
détail dans son parcours c'est à dire
que on a tous en soi probablement une
aspiration courage mais le scoutisme et
d'autres formations nous y préparent
pour le jour où on a besoin
véritablement de mettre son courage en
jeu est-ce que est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
dire que sa vie ou à tout le monde son
parcours c'était moi une forme de
préparation morale pour se tenir droit
dans de tels événements alors si la
question est est-ce que le scoutisme est
bienvenu dans la formation d'une
personnalité c'est pas moi qui vais vous
dire le contraire non pas que j'ai été
scout je savais même pas que ça existait
de formation je ne savais pas que ça
existait dans mon enfance donc
où j'ai grandi il y avait pas ce type
d'engagement mais en ville il y avait ce
type d'engagement et mes enfants ont été
scouts et je suis tout à fait acquis à
l'idée certains de ce qu'il y a quelque
chose d'une de l'édification d'une
personnalité de la construction d'une
personnalité dans les activités que que
Madame Powell a inventé autre autrefois
et donc
oui sans aucun doute il y a pas que ça
je vous rappelle que nous avons plaidé
pour qu'il y ait un service civil
obligatoire en France ou en tout cas un
service civil universel en France c'est
difficile à construire
mais c'est à notre avis très important
pour des années qu'on en parle et il se
passerait
pas du tout
[Musique]
son universalité est repoussé mais il y
a aujourd'hui
sarahi est chargé de ça au gouvernement
il y a aujourd'hui
du service civil par dizaines de
milliers de jeunes qui acceptent de
s'engager peut vous dire que dans que
dans une ville comme la mienne service
civile d'autres formes unicités qui
prennent plusieurs mois d'engagement de
la vie des jeunes précisément pour qu'il
découvre autre chose de leur vie ce
service est d'ailleurs Sarah aéré a
répondu sur Europe 1 lors d'une matinale
il est parfois moqué par une certaine
partie de la classe politique et pour en
revenir quand même au profil d'Henri
certaines réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux certes minoritaires ont
relativise et son rôle moquer sa foi
ringardiser ses mots un article dans
Libération écrit par Daniel Schneiderman
le cible aussi de quoi est le révélateur
d'ailleurs vous voyez d'ailleurs ce cet
article est-ce que ce est-ce que ça
est-ce qu'on ne peut pas finalement
autour d'une telle figure avoir un
consensus
j'avais commencé de décrire les les
vagues de de d'absurdité qui se sont
déployés autour de cette affaire
première vague d'absurdité ceux qui
auraient voulu pour correspondre à leur
schéma qu'il fut musulman
immigré syrien musulman manque de chance
apparemment je sais pas si c'est si
c'est vrai il dit chrétien Dorian
et deuxièmement quand Henri dancaine ce
garçon courageux est intervenu les gens
en Dias mais c'est suspects il y a là
quelque chose on voudrait nous entraîner
à être dans dans cet univers de du
prosélytisme religieux il y a rien de
tout ça il y a des des drames il y a des
gens qui
perdent la raison pour des raisons qu'on
ne connaît pas et il y a des gens
courageux qui essaient d'empêcher le
drame de se produire et on devrait tout
enfin tous ensemble prendre cela aussi
simplement en pensant qu'il y a d'un
côté des éléments à bannir et de l'autre
des exemples à suivre des exemples à
suivre de quoi est-ce le symptôme
finalement quand vous avez décrit le
courage l'abnégation vous dites que
c'est presque un élan humain qui est
quand même remis en cause aujourd'hui je
pense qu'elle doit beaucoup interpeller
ce qui
nous soyons dans des temps de boussole
égarées je n'ai aucun doute et vous non
plus et aucun de ceux qui sont autour de
la table
pas seulement en France comme on
pourrait croire
et c'est un drame qui se produit dans de
très large partie du monde
spécialement hélas en Occident
le fait que les sociétés que nous avons
construites autour de d'une certaine
idée de l'humanisme on va dire comme ça
cette
Nord perdu boussole devrait monter le
nord et on sait plus ce qu'elle pointe
comme azimut
il y a aucun doute et dans ce temps de
boussole perdu qu'est-ce qui triomphe
c'est le sectarisme alors je dis le
sectarisme au sens le plus large du
terme tous ceux qui
veulent trouver une explication
aux dérives du monde dans leur obsession
obsession religieuse ou antirigeuse on
vient de citer deux exemples qui vont
dans ce sens là obsession
anti-scientifique c'est le pour moi
c'est le même genre de dérive
obsession de de perte de repères et
notamment de négation
des
origines de l'histoire du patrimoine et
de ce que nous sommes comme être humain
toutes ces obsessions là ce que vous
appelez le walkisme
toutes ces obsessions là sont exactement
du même ordre c'est un temps dans lequel
le ce qui nous permettait de nous relier
les uns aux autres ce que nous croyons
tous ensemble de plus élémentaires
au-delà des engagements tout cela est
aujourd'hui nié et il est vrai que c'est
une des civilisations on ne passe
aggraver et les secours à cette
dissivisation des réactions le sursaut
est-il l'avenir notamment sur des sujets
aussi importants que la politique
migratoire l'asile etc la classe
politique française en effervescence sur
ce sujet une courte pause et on en parle
François Bayrou
et avec notre invité ce dimanche
président du MoDem maire de Pau François
Bayrou après le choc
d'Annecy quelle sursaut nous allons
parler dans quelques instants de la
politique migratoire de notre
souveraineté de la politique d'asile
mais pour le moment vous êtes revenus
sur le mot de décibilisation François
Baro mais quand il y a un processus de
décibilisation c'est qu'il y a des
causes une accélération quelles sont
justement ces causes selon vous alors
j'ai lu beaucoup de commentaires mais
rarement mort a été aussi bien choisi
que ce mot de décibilisation qu'est-ce
qui veut dire ce mot quand on dit des
civilisations ça veut dire d'abord qu'il
y a une civilisation qu'il y a eu une
civilisation
et cette civilisation elle dit des
choses extrêmement précises que nous
avons construites au travers des siècles
millénaires peut-être
elle dit d'abord que il y a
au-dessus des intérêts de chacun
personnels ou de groupe ou collectif de
communauté au-dessus de ces intérêts là
il y a quelque chose qui mérite d'être
défendu
il y a quelque chose qui mérite qu'on se
dépasse il y a quelque chose de l'ordre
de la transcendance comme on dit même si
cette transcendance peut être
interprétée différemment même si chacun
peut en avoir sa propre perception mais
l'idée qu'il y a quelque chose au-dessus
de nous qui nous donne des raisons de
vivre où nous pouvons trouver des
raisons de vivre c'est encore une fois
l'image que qu'on évoquait de ce garçon
qui qui affronte
l'horreur
c'est très important pour l'éducation
c'est très important pour la
transmission c'est très important la
civilisation ça se construit au travers
du temps c'est très important pour ce
qui concerne le patrimoine
des siècles le temps de construire ça et
on a l'impression que tout se
déconstruit très rapidement pourquoi
d'abord on a toujours eu cette
impression un peu plus maintenant
qu'auparavant oui mais enfin comme vous
savez Socrate Platon rapporte que
Socrate disait des choses de cet ordre
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la République le dit aussi
le diagnostic a des raisons de marquer
des événements par la parole du premier
responsable public du pays celui-là en
étant alors vous dites quelles sont les
causes oh ben les causes on les a tous
les jours sous les yeux
la première c'est que on avait pris
l'habitude qu'il y ait des autorités
pour définir la vérité je sais pas très
bien ce que la vérité est
mais
de ce point de vue là toutes les
autorités sont mises en cause et on a
assisté au travers du temps elle avait
déjà mises
années au pouvoir vous allez être
interpellé parce que si vous ne regardez
dans le rétroviseur que 6 années alors
vous allez vous ne pouvez rien
comprendre à l'histoire on reprend
évidemment
au travers du temps les autorités
religieuses ont été profondément mis en
cause dans un dans un dans un pays comme
le nôtre en Europe et en France pendant
très longtemps les régimes politiques se
sont construits sur l'autorité
religieuse a été en cause l'autorité
politique a été mise en cause est-ce que
vous avez un moment de bascule et le les
autorités philosophiques ont tout fait
pas seulement pour être mise en cause
j'ai fini 158 l'essence laissez-moi
finir parce que c'est bon et au bout du
compte avec le covid à quoi a-t-on
assisté la dernière autorité qui était
reconnue et respecté par tout le monde
c'était pas seulement scientifique
c'était médical les médecins avaient une
espèce de de
qualité de rôle à la fois scientifique
et moral indiscuter et tous les Français
les ont découvert sur sur vos plateaux
en train de se déchirer les uns les
autres et ça a fini avec diagnostic est
posé effondrement des civilisations
autorités politiques religieuses
scientifiques etc et plus je reviens
quelque chose de plus prosaïque monsieur
Bayeux parce que depuis l'attaque
d'Annecy quand même là les remises en
cause et les coups de boutoir par
rapport à nos mécanismes du droit
d'asile sont sérieuses est-ce que cet
acte pour vous est clairement liée à des
failles de notre politique migratoire
alors qu'il y ait des failles de notre
politique migratoire je n'ai aucun doute
et qui pourrait le nier est-ce que cet
événement est lié à des failles de notre
politique migratoire franchement ça
demanderait à être prouvé et pour moi
c'est très
cet homme là est en Europe depuis 10 ans
pas en France en Suède il a obtenu
l'asile en Suède il a ses papiers
il est marié et il a un enfant dans dans
son pays d'accueil est-ce qu'on pouvait
deviner discerner
c'est extrêmement difficile alors je
veux bien qu'on en fasse une théorie
mais
en train on est en train précisément en
ce moment au Parlement européen de
mettre en place des des une organisation
qui permet d'éviter ce genre de feuilles
jusqu'à maintenant donc c'est la ville
c'est une faille le fait qu'il était
présent sur le territoire national
français je n'ai pas dit ça alors où est
la faille essayez de ne pas j'ai dit
précisément que il n'avait pas dans
cette affaire d'illustration
spéciale de failles mais on va aller
plus loin on est en train au Parlement
européen de mettre en place une
organisation qui va permettre
tous les personnes demandent dans
l'asile d'être repéré sur un seul
fichier c'est à dire jusqu'à maintenant
vous veniez demander l'asile en Italie
après vous demandiez l'asile en France
techniquement après
la formule qui revient souvent le droit
d'asile dévoyé diriez-vous aussi que le
droit d'asile est dévoyé aujourd'hui que
c'est devenu une filière migratoire à
part entière
le droit d'asile est utilisé par un
certain nombre de gens qui relèvent pas
de l'asile pour avoir des papiers
et ils sont malheureusement en France
rejetés quand ils doivent l'être
beaucoup trop longtemps après la date
qui aurait été efficace et utile et on
est en train je sais que le gouvernement
il travaille que le ministre de
l'Intérieur il travaille tout le monde
est en train de changer ça bien sûr que
c'est tout le monde quand il faut trois
ou quatre ans pour décréter ou pour
décider que quelqu'un n'a pas droit à
l'asile évidemment
c'est là c'est une faille parce que
pendant ce temps-là
s'installe dans la société ils vivent
des vies après ça devient extrêmement
difficile il y a un problème un second
problème qui est le qui est très
important c'est que les pays d'origine
refusent le retour
mais attendez restons sur le premier
problème Jean-Pierre Chevènement dit
dans le Journal du Dimanche ce droit
d'asile initialement réservé au
combattant la liberté est aujourd'hui
clairement détournée de son but initial
vous parlez de l'Europe est-ce que nous
sommes encore décisionnaires parce que
c'est l'Union européenne qui a participé
de ce justement dire que que ce droit
d'asile soit dévoyé aujourd'hui
l'Union européenne c'est nous la
présentation qui consiste à dire c'est
eux l'Union européenne qui nous empêche
de l'Union européenne c'est nous il n'y
a pas de décision en Europe qui puisse
se prendre sur notre assentiment
et on voit d'ailleurs qu'il y a des
tensions
n'aide pas la France lorsqu'elle veut
reprendre un ministre sa politique
migratoire il reconnaît que c'est
peut-être un peu c'est pas seulement
nous l'Union européenne
l'Union européenne c'est nous que nous
ayons par le passé
au travers des gouvernements successifs
cette réalité était déjà celle-là il y a
3 ans il y a 4 ans
migratoire comme le demande la droite et
l'extrême droite en France est-ce qu'il
faut restreindre le droit d'asile alors
vous voyez vous dites retrouvez la
souveraineté en matière migratoire c'est
restreindre le droit de d'asile vous
faites une équivalence que
qui n'est pas absolument évidente
moi je crois qu'il faut avoir des
attitudes simples
je crois que quelqu'un qui vient en
France qui veut travailler
qui veut apprendre la langue
qui comprend que la France c'est pas un
territoire c'est une histoire et une
civilisation qui est décidé à les
respecter dans l'état actuel de notre
notre pays avec les immenses difficultés
que nous avons pour trouver des gens qui
travaillent pour trouver des gens qui
acceptent des emplois
ils peuvent trouver leur place
aujourd'hui pardon vous trouvez que
l'intégration à la similation fonctionne
non mais vous voyez bien que que vous
tirez
vous tirez non mais vous tirez dans un
au-delà de ce que je veux dire
je crois que l'intégration pourrait
fonctionner et qu'elle ne fonctionne pas
et je crois qu'on n'est pas assez
exigeant sur ces critères là et le on
vous avait été au pouvoir pendant des
années également je suis pas sûr d'avoir
été personnellement au pouvoir pendant
des années vous avez été ministre
monsieur Bayeux
donc et donc vous n'étiez pas né et donc
ce peut-être aurions-nous pu faire mieux
mais j'étais ministre en particulier de
l'éducation nationale
et je prétends que nous avons alors
défendu cette idée de transmission de
transmission de l'essentiel
pas seulement de connaissances mais de
l'idée de ce qui nous porte et ce qui
nous permet d'aller plus loin on va s'y
arrêter justement marquer une courte
pause sur Europe 1 et cnews continuent
quand même avec l'offensive de la droite
Éric ciotique il dit qu'aujourd'hui la
France vit une submersion migratoire
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord sur ce
constat que pensez-vous de ce qui se
passe au Danemark avec la politique des
sociaux-démocrates surtout ces sujets on
se retrouve dans quelques minutes à
peine
et la suite de notre émission après
l'attaque et le choc d'Annecy une partie
de la classe politique remet en cause la
politique migratoire européenne
s'interroge sur notre souveraineté les
LR François bayeron ont déposé une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
avec un volet important sur l'asile à la
une du Parisien ce matin Éric Ciotti
demande solennellement être reçu à
l'Élysée il veut que tout part de leur
texte du texte des DLR il qualifie la
situation de la France d'une avec une
subversion migratoire c'est une version
migratoire vous êtes d'accord sur ce
diagnostic
parmi les symptômes qui nous font
conclure que la situation du pays est
pas formidable il y a celui-là
mais vous voyez on va on va on va
s'arrêter une seconde le brexit a été
décidé la sortie de la Grande-Bretagne
de l'Union européenne a été décidé à
partir de cet argument là vous vous
souvenez du du slogan de Boris Johnson
qui était reprendre le contrôle
il y avait à l'époque 300 000 immigrés
qui rentraient par an en Angleterre sont
sortis ils ont dit on va nous-mêmes
désormais être souverainde vous savez
combien il y a eu des milliers qui sont
rentrés en Angleterre cette année 600
000 le Danemark le double non mais
attendez le double
souveraineté ils le font et moi je vous
dis que vous ne pouvez pas
trouver une souveraineté qui ne se place
dans une entente une union avec ses
voisins
souveraineté j'ai pas entendu c'est le
cadre que vous proposez le cadre
européen
ça n'est pas le cadre que je propose
ce n'est pas ce que je dis je ne laisse
pas dévoiler ce que je dis c'est pas que
je propose le cadre européen je dis
quelque chose de beaucoup plus lourd
peut-être réglé au niveau européen il ne
peut y avoir de solutions que si nous
les préparons et les appliquons ensemble
parce que sans ça un pays qui a des
frontières de
milliers de kilomètres comme la France
sur combien de continents sur quasiment
tous les continents mais c'est un frexit
l'expression
de la majorité
a le droit si ce n'est le devoir de
contribuer à la réflexion générale ils
le font et pour moi je ne m'enfusque pas
je trouve pas qu'il y a quelque chose de
de
le président des républicains demande à
être reçu par le Président de la
République pour discuter c'est légitime
des traités européens c'est ce qui
propose avec leur proposition de loi
constitution vous savez bien que ça ne
se fera pas donc ça se fera pas parce
que sans ça les autres vont sortir des
traités européens à notre détriment
quand vous êtes dans une famille dire je
veux sortir non c'est pas de la
démagogie c'est chacun et c'est
ce sont de grands partis politiques les
républicains les socialistes qui
essaient difficilement de trouver un
chemin ce sont des grands partis de la
République moi je suis pour le
pluralisme et je suis pour qui chacun et
sa voix et sa place reconnu c'est comme
ça que ça devrait fonctionner au lieu
d'être le bazar effroyable que
l'Assemblée nationale est aujourd'hui
leur proposition sont légitimes mais
malgré tout par exemple quand elles sont
juste
l'ancien Premier ministre n'est pas
Philippe fait cette sortie très
remarquée sur les accords de 68 ce n'est
pas rien dans notre pays avec l'Algérie
qui prévoit des règles dérogatoires
depuis tant d'années pour qu'elle soit
supprimée est-ce que est-ce qu'il a
raison est-ce qu'il a tort l'ancien
Premier ministre et l'occupe quand même
assez important dans notre pays pardon
il occupe quand même une place
importante
vous savez combien il y a de de
d'enfants d'Algérien ou de
ressortissants algérien en France il y
en a entre deux millions et 2 millions
et demi ils sont des ils sont des
citoyens ils travaillent ils vivent et
l'idée qu'on focalise sur l'Algérie tous
les problèmes que nous avons est une
idée à discuter il y a des responsables
algériens qui pensent que ces accords ne
sont pas bons
et y compris parfois des responsables de
premier plan
et la situation entre
des faveurs quand même en leur défaveur
non mais il conviennent que ça ne va pas
nous dire que il doit Philippe
stigmatise les Algériens ou les Français
vous savez bien que j'ai pas dit ça ni
de près ni de loin je veux dire
simplement que si vous
focalisez la totalité du problème sur
cette question sur la question de
l'Algérie à mon avis vous vous trompez
et
touche pas au cadre européen à quoi on
touche pour résoudre les problèmes
c'est-à-dire les
on a des problèmes nombreux le premier
c'est l'insertion dans l'emploi le
deuxième c'est la politique de santé
mentale dans notre pays parce que ce
qu'on ce qu'on observe là et
troisièmement oui en effet il y a à
reprendre la totalité de nos relations
avec l'Algérie avec le Maroc aussi je
moi je suis pas satisfait des
tensions très importantes qui entre la
France et le Maroc c'est aussi le cas
avec des pays africains ce que nous
n'avons pas défini aujourd'hui c'est le
cadre qui permet de savoir qui a le
droit enfin ou qui est
admis à venir et les obligations qui
doivent être remplies
à ce sujet du Danemark voilà un pays qui
est dirigé par des sociaux-démocrates
nous sommes d'accord qui appliquent une
politique ferme certains diront lucides
sur cet aspect sur l'asile également
est-ce que vous estimez que c'est un
modèle ou est-ce que vous estimez que on
ne peut pas s'en inspirer peut-être
compte tenu de critères géographiques
démographiques et autres alors cette
politique ils l'ont définie après
combien de temps et après quel autre
politique
que vous êtes vous regardez aussi du
côté du Danemark je n'ai pas de modèle
qui ne soit conçu et pensé dans le cadre
français
l'idée que on va aller chercher ailleurs
dans des circonstances totalement
différentes vous savez ce qui s'est
passé au Danemark vous savez comment
combien la vie politique danoise a été
traumatisée sur ces sujets là
et quel et quel changement alors c'est
pas parce qu'ils sont sociaux-démocrates
que je vais y trouver un modèle je pense
que ils ont raison sur un point les
peuples ne peuvent pas vivre sans donner
à leur citoyen la certitude que le
modèle national
européen dans lequel ils sont sera
préservés dans l'avenir une très grande
partie
[Musique]
disait qu'il s'inquiétait aujourd'hui du
fait que la France ne soit plus une
évidence la France pourrait mourir
autrement dit les peuples européens ont
cette angoisse existentielle aujourd'hui
est-ce que sur l'angoisse que vous
partagez j'ai même écrit sur ce sur ce
sujet je
vous enverrai mon dernier livre qui
traite de ce sujet
c'est la raison profonde de la
déstabilisation des esprits dans notre
pays
sur ces sujets là
le sujet c'est que un grand nombre de
Français ont le sentiment que ce à quoi
il croit
les cadres dans lequel il vivait sont
profondément déstabilisés et risque dans
l'avenir et risque dans l'avenir de ne
plus être transmis à leurs enfants et ce
n'est que le sentiment c'est un fait
c'est d'abord un sentiment mais il y a
aussi des éléments de fête de la
sécurité il y a il y a aussi des
éléments de
il faut pas que vous moquiez les peuples
quand ils sont inquiets
le sentiment
d'insécurités
c'est un fait social
les sécurités réelles au sentiment
d'insécurité donc je vous conseille la
même question pour moi
d'insécurité c'est un fait
et il importe peu de savoir s'il est
créé par des centaines de faits ou par
un fait comme celui qu'on vient de vivre
et le sentiment de fragilité
de notre pays de notre peuple de notre
société et de notre civilisation c'est
un fait et c'est pourquoi j'ai tellement
insisté tout à l'heure lorsque on
parlait d'immigration pour dire que
certes il est légitime que des gens
pourchasser viennent chez nous à
condition qu'ils acceptent que nous
sommes non pas un territoire où on peut
faire ce qu'on veut mais un pays avec
son histoire et son patrimoine avec ses
coutumes avec ses mœurs et avec sa
langue et si nous ne rassurons pas nos
compatriotes sur ce point alors nous
aurons de très graves difficultés parce
que vous évoquez de vous-même finalement
le projet de société peut-être même
projet de civilisation
oserais-je dit on va consacrer cette
dernière partie à cela avec aussi le
remaniement parce qu'il faut les hommes
et les femmes pour animer un tel projet
une courte pause et on se retrouve
et la dernière partie de cette émission
bien sûr avec notre invité François
Bayron on a beaucoup parlé de projets de
de société pour l'incarner il faut des
femmes des hommes la piste d'un
remaniement avant l'été serait
privilégié François Bayrou pourquoi
est-ce que Elisabeth borne a démérité
est-elle déjà usé selon vous
non d'abord
la question que vous posez à juste titre
si souvent
celle de des personnes pour
occuper les fonctions et notamment la
fonction de Premier ministre c'est une
question qui se pose à deux personnes en
même temps le président de la République
et le Premier ministre ou la première
ministre et c'est dans leur tête à tête
et dans leur rapport personnel et leur
franchise personnelle que la réponse se
trouve personne d'autre
n'a cette réponse là vous savez ce que
je pense depuis longtemps
j'ai toujours pensé que le premier
ministre n'était pas un collaborateur au
contraire de ce que Nicolas Sarkozy
avait décrit autrefois je pense que le
premier ministre et le chef du
gouvernement et que c'est à lui qu'il
revient notamment dans une période où la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale n'est
pas prédéfini c'est à lui qu'il revient
d'impulser une politique
moi je ne suis pas président de la
République
au chef de l'État ces derniers jours
ceux qui craignent de voir débarquer à
nouveau transfuges de la droite à
Matignon de Julien de Normandie ancien
ministre de l'agriculture Richard
Ferrand ancien président de l'Assemblée
encore Sébastien le Cornu actuel
ministre des Armées reviennent
régulièrement pour contrebalancer Gérald
Darmanin ou autre est-ce que ce sont des
profils adéquats selon vous
[Musique]
il faut j'ai souvent repris cette
expression il faut à Matignon une
capacité d'autonomie
et une complicité très grande avec le
président de la République c'est un
mouton à 5 pattes et bien il faut
chercher les moutons à 5 pages parfois
la société civile pour moi
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron elle a été
acquise sur le socle central
et c'est parce qu'elle était sur le
socle central que nous avons une
innoforce pour que pour quel triomphe
c'est dans ce socle central que se
trouve la réponse pour moi
et après dans le socle central il faut
un nouveau Premier ministre c'est
nécessaire aujourd'hui un an après les
deux invité le président de la
République et poser lui la question vous
êtes un homme politique vous êtes
responsable politique à ce que j'en sais
vous avez un avis sur la question est-ce
que est-ce que Madame borne a été
finalement trop abîmé par la crise des
retraites pour pouvoir je pense que le
profil qui avait été nommé à Matignon
par le Président de la République
c'est lui qui l'a choisi c'est lui qui
l'a voulu et c'est entre elle et lui que
cette question doit se poser on va pas
quand on sait que c'est d'abord Madame
Catherine Vautrin qui était vraiment
jusqu'au dernier moment à cette place là
mais allons sur le mot choisi par contre
vous avez l'oreille du président et
est-il vrai et François bayraud vous
avez menacé de quitter la majorité c'est
les anciens les républicains Gérald
Darmanin ou Sébastien le Cornut était
nommé Premier ministre je n'ai pas fait
tout ça pour me retrouver avec des
copies de Nicolas Sarkozy à Matignon
auriez-vous testé
comme vous savez la manière dont les
journaux sont écrits vous ne devriez pas
attacher sérieusement tant de tant de
sérieux à leurs affirmations non je je
n'enbosse que ce que j'ai moi-même dit
et moi-même signé et donc et donc non je
dis je viens de vous dire clairement les
choses je pense que l'élection des
manuel Macron n'est pas un accident
je pense que ça correspond à un moment
historique de basculement et que ce
moment historique de basculement c'est
un moment de rassemblement et que c'est
dans un socle central du pays vous voyez
bien avec les extrêmes de chaque côté
c'est dans ce que central que doit se
trouver l'inspiration du gouvernement et
l'inspiration du gouvernement vous allez
pas la faire en disant
suffisamment large pour dépasser le
seuil et donc
majorité nullement répondu ça mais
entendez bien pardon il n'appartient pas
au socle central selon vous je vous
demande de de vous reporter à
ce qui s'est passé en 2017 ce qui s'est
passé en 2017 on est sorti de
l'affrontement droite contre gauche
qui était délétère pour le pays
destructeur pour le pays et on est passé
à une vision complètement différente que
le Président de la République a appelé
du dépassement que j'appelle pour moi
central depuis longtemps cette vision là
elle permet de proposer au pays une
orientation et un projet qui dépasse les
affrontements
il y a des gens qui ont intérêt à dire
ça mais si on les suivait on aurait de
graves accidents parce que je
pars
on reviendrait à l'impuissance dans
laquelle on s'est trouvé pendant des
décennies depuis aller 30 ans on a vécu
des choses qui nous qui ont empêché le
pays de faire face à temps aux
difficultés qui sont les siennes on a
cité des exemples mais je vais vous dire
le le
tréfond de ce que je pense on a parlé
d'immigration on a parlé de pression
extérieure on a de l'Europe moi je vais
vous dire ce que je crois les problèmes
du pays ils ne viennent pas de
l'extérieur
viennent pas de l'immigration ils
viennent pas de l'Europe ils viennent
pas des déséquilibres planétaires ils
viennent de l’imper les problèmes du
pays ils viennent de l'intérieur c'est
parce que depuis des décennies nous
n'avons pas été capables de redresser
notre éducation nationale nous n'avons
pas été capables de retrouver les
chemins de la production
c'est parce que nous n'avons pas été
capables de trouver un contrat social
durable intéressant parce que il n'est
pas durable aujourd'hui puisque est-ce
que parce que nous n'avons pas la
souveraineté et les manettes à ce sujet
absolument pas nous n'avons pas été
capables parce que
alternance après alternance les
majorités les majorités successives les
majorités successives je ne suis pas au
pouvoir monsieur les majorités
successives depuis tout ce temps-là
passez leur temps à détruire l'une après
l'autre ce que l'on avait fait on vient
de vivre la réforme des retraites et on
n'a pas dit la vérité aux Français qui
est toute simple c'est que les retraites
sont payées à crédit c'est-à-dire qui le
gouvernement les médias les médias
parce que c'était plus c'était plus
facile ça facilitait les choses donc sur
la réforme de retraite je précise
réforme que vous avez en tous les cas
sur la communication vous êtes pas allé
de main morte vous avez dit que sur la
forme ça n'allait pas du tout la manière
dont ça va laisser de lourde c'est pas
sur la forme
[Musique]
pour reprendre la réforme des retraites
mais c'est pas le seul sujet
qui n'a pas fait les Ford pédagogie
c'est le gouvernement oui sans doute et
les médias ne l'ont pas aidé j'ai notre
rôle j'ai dit oui oui aussi c'est un
rôle civique on est tous co-responsables
j'ai édité au commissariat aux plans une
analyse chiffrée et précise
indiquant ce que savait un tout petit
nombre de responsables
et c'est bien je vous remercie de vous
référer aux bons auteurs et donc
qui fait que les pensions de retraite
qui sont aujourd'hui payés aux Français
elles sont pas payées comment le croit
par répartition par les contributions
par les par les cotisations de ceux qui
travaillent
et des employeurs elles sont payées par
l'emprunt par la dette et donc on fait
les pensions en créant des dettes pour
ceux qui viennent c'est insupportable et
c'est un de ces problèmes j'ai dit
l'éducation j'ai dit celui-là j'ai dit
un modèle social durable en 2017 il y a
un moment de dépassement on est quitté
le clivage gauche-droite mais un nouveau
clivage apparaît régulièrement et en
démocratie a toujours des clivages
comment nommeriez-vous le présent
clivage si c'est pas gauche droite
je pense que le clivage principal c'est
responsabilité contre irresponsabilité
non
le monopole là je vais je vais expliquer
ce que ce que je dis lorsque vous
présentez aux citoyens
une
des thèses selon lesquelles
ils ne sont pour rien dans les
difficultés du pays mais c'est la faute
de
la faute des riches d'un côté des plus
riches de de tout ce dont vous
connaissez le nom de des Arnaud Bolloré
de et vous dites c'est de leur faute il
confie ce que la richesse du pays et
lorsque d'un autre côté vous dites c'est
la faute des étrangers c'est la faute de
l'immigration vous êtes dans
l'irresponsabilité et quand vous dites
Yaka il faut qu'on vous êtes dans
l'irresponsabilité et la France
insoumise pour les nommer sont dans les
irresponsabilités oui
sans le moindre doute et donc la
question c'est
[Musique]
j'essaie de ne pas j'essaie de ne pas
simplifier ni caricaturer il y a c'est
pas parce que quelqu'un n'est pas
d'accord avec moi que je pense qu'il est
illégitime au contraire j'ai toujours
plaidé dans ma vie pour le pluralisme
c'est-à-dire pour qu'on reconnaisse que
la politique ça consiste pas à faire
triompher ses idées sur celle des autres
ça consiste à créer un cadre de débat
dans lequel chacun puisse faire entendre
sa voix et où s'élabore peu à peu en
donnant à tous les citoyens tous les
éléments de compréhension le choix du
pays c'est pas du tout ce qu'on fait
pour l'instant on va conclure il nous
reste très peu de temps votre voix le
choix du pays pour 2027 vous êtes
toujours j'allais dire dans les starting
blocks
vous voyez bien que
le principe tout ce que nous vivons
est suffisamment éloigné de 2027 pour
qu'on n'ait pas la j'allais dire
j'allais dire la bêtise de se situer
dans cette course là et j'ajoute une
chose c'est que tous les favoris à
l'avance perdent c'est une des lois de
la Cinquième République donc je n'aime
vraiment on verra tout ça merci François
on verra tout ça effectivement merci
François bayraud nous avons démarré par
l'essentiel l'émotion l'hommage le
rassemblement le partage et justement
c'est à suivre sur nos antennes le
rassemblement citoyen que aura lieu dans
quelques instants à Annecy moment de
partage de reconnaissance évidemment
après le choc et l'attaque je vous
remercie d'avoir été notre invité je
remercie mes camarades Matthieu et
Stéphane et on vous souhaite tous un
très très bon dimanche sur Europe 1 et
cnews merci encore